Speaker 1: Let's try another international
call.
Let's go to Sayad from Bangladesh, said you're
on the air.
Speaker 3: Oh, hello.
Thank you for actually selecting me.
I have been trying to get on your call for
a vote.
I'd say a week, I guess.
My pleasure.
So, OK.
The thing I'm going to ask you is literally,
you know, like sort of, you know, your opinion,
I would really like to, you know, like, you
know, how do you feel about this or hear me
out.
So as you can, you know completely.
Yes.
I am not from America.
Right.
But I get, you know, like in a lot of, you
know, like because of a lot of international
issues and stuff, we end up like listening
to, you know, American politics and, you know,
like basically international involvement and
basically so during this, you know, like pandemic
and, you know, the other stuff, when I had
much more time to actually, you know, look
through all of the stuff, I have noticed something
very surprising in, let's say, in America
right now.
So hear me out on this one.
Apparently, I can see that most of the people
who are, you know, let's say they are right
wingers and all the religious and whatnot,
and they are basically, you know, like trying
to, you know, like they have their own set
of ideologies, let's say, and have their own
set of ideologies.
And like, no, let's see the Muslim populations
in the West, they are kind of like in a scenario
where they sort of feel like they are in some
kind of, you know, political homelessness.
That is something that I'm going to say.
So let's say, you know, like.
Someone is like a practicing Muslim, let's
say, and, you know, he wants to, you know,
basically follow traditional stop and go religious
worshiping and other stuff like that and,
you know.
Basically, a person like that oftentimes doesn't
get along with, you know, let's say, you know,
insane.
Someone who is very hard core left the and
then you have, you know, on the other side,
the right wingers who are actually, you know,
like they claim to be religious and, you know,
they are not practitioners of mostly Christianity.
And then they have problems with, you know,
Muslims.
Right.
So I have seen this scenario where Muslims
feel like political homelessness and like
any kind of I say, you know, like the right
wing people, I would say that, you know, they're
basically shooting themselves in their foot,
you know, when they are, you know, doing all
this, you know, like, let's say some sort
of anti-Muslim stuff.
Yeah.
And, you know, and then then they're wondering,
why are we losing.
Right.
I think it's
Speaker 1: I think it's a very astute point.
So if you consider the religious Muslim community,
you have folks who culturally are really more
in line with the religious Christian community,
often in terms of the role they want to see
religion play in civil government, in terms
of cultural norms, in terms of social norms.
But Republicans in the United States, they
are like that only with regard to Christianity.
And sometimes they'll pretend with Judaism
as well, although really they're often anti-Semitic.
But there's is more complicated.
Speaker 3: I know.
Speaker 1: So that's where the Muslims would
would find a cultural social home.
But the Republicans don't want them.
And then on the left, those very same religious
Muslims would often say, oh, these folks want
secularism.
That's not what I want either.
And it leaves these folks sort of out out
in a in a no man's land.
I think it's is a very astute analysis.
And I think you're completely right, Sayyid.
Speaker 3: And it is going to like, let me
explain a scenario like I'm going to say it,
Speaker 1: I have so many people holding,
I'm going to let you go now because we've
done I think we've done a good amount today.
But call back.
OK, but I love the point you made.
OK.
OK, very good.
All right, Saied from Bangladesh, extraordinarily
good point.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
I'm going right back to the phones in a moment